from 1950s American baking to modern-day
London Tareq Maloof set up cupcake house
hummingbird to revive his love of US
baked goods just like mother used to
make well maybe not in this case
there was virtually no baking at all in
my own home growing up it's not
something that my mother did you know I
made brownies and cupcakes with maybe
some of her friends he set up his first
shop on London's Portobello Road in 2004
ten years later he has six in London and
two in Dubai not the most rapid of
expansions but did he want to go any
faster we could have expanded a lot
faster yes but I feel that it would have
really affected the quality of our
product we bake on site freshly every
day and that doesn't take well to a very
rapid expansion one way the hummingbird
has branched out though has been with
cookery books Tareq has authored three
and sold 800,000 copies worldwide
so is encouraging home baking good or
bad for business I love it that people
bake at home and some people who have
never been to our shops and they have
our books made our stuff might make a
little special detour when they come
into London what worries a businessman
like yourself Tareq - do you worry about
anything to do with the business where
do we where do I begin
I have a whole litany of worries I can
tell you about I always was employed
before and in a completely different
sector so I don't know what's normal for
my sector if we haven't you know taken X
out tens of thousands that we usually do
I'll like panic but then I'll hear from
someone else they'll be like that famous
restaurant that everyone goes to takes
this much per week and I'm thinking a
week
more than that and it's just the
cupcakes I think everyone worries about
making sure the stuff are happy the
customers are happy is that what running
your own business is about worrying
about things yes
well for me much for me I'm sure there
are some people who never worry about
things but I'm glad I worry because then
I make sure that I can't resolve any
issues that happen